oh sorry I'm late I was at freddy
fazbears good old Freddy fazbear's both
of your son's birthday well you know so
what are we doing here today today we're
here to take down a man by the name of
Wilfred warp stache he's the prime
suspect of one of the most gruesome
murders we've seen on this side of town
he was caught having an affair and
terminated all witnesses
a steamy husband his wife the neighbor
their dog and allegedly their baby
allegedly yeah he burnt down the house
afterwards we'll we can find the remains
of everyone with a child chances of
survival are slim
we believe these killings were done in
this fashion due to the fact the night
before it watch the dear sisters
schedule Saturday Night Live
rip them right off didn't family guide
you the same thing well the important
thing is this case is important to me
we're going after a sicko right here I
will not rest until I bring them to the
suite on curtain showers of justice
it's the place oh yeah I'm horrible
let's do what it lets let's do it once
we're gone like oh I don't draw my gun
unless there's a crisis situation I mean
you've heard the reports gone to the
leading cause of
I think I hear some sweet South news
coming from that direction
do it I am more relaxed now it was an
accident I swear
ghost this is one of those crisis
situations stop right there Hey look
looks like you like to use excessive
force annually
you
No
just the worst
oh what'd they do to you what do they do
why I know you're thinking it's the same
thing I think every leg
wrong
Oh